[Music]
in the previous few videos we learned
about Pascal's triangle and the concept
of permutations and combinations here
let's see how we apply these to the
binomial theorem before we begin let's
quickly review the concepts we've seen
so far
remember the Pascal's triangle right
here's how it looks we know that each
term in the Pascal's triangle is the sum
of the other two terms above it and do
you remember what the Pascal's triangle
gives us in the expansion you're right
it gives us the binomial coefficients
what was the next concept we had studied
yes its permutations and combinations we
will be requiring only combinations here
we all remember the formula of
combinations right yes it was NCR equals
n factorial over n minus R factorial
times R factorial
what does NCR mean here NCR represents n
items taken are at a time where the
order in which the items are chosen does
not matter now let me ask you one
question can you tell me the value of
2c0
yes we can use this formula we get it as
two factorial over zero factorial
multiplied by two factorial we know that
0 factorial is 1 so we get this value as
1 now by using the same formula can you
tell me the value of 2 c1
yes it's 2 now try getting the value of
2 c2 as well do you get it as 1 yes
that's right
we got the three values as 1 to 1 now
take a look at the Pascal's triangle did
you notice something yes we have these
same values in the second row do you
think there is some relation here
between combinations and the Pascal's
triangle let's find out calculate the
values of 3 c0 3 c1 3 C 2 and 3 C 3 by
yourself
did you get it as one three three one
you're absolutely right
have you seen these stumps previously
anywhere oh yes these terms form the
third row of the Pascal's triangle what
can you conclude from this can you
derive any relation between the Pascal's
triangle and combinations give it a try
each number in the Pascal's triangle is
given by a combination NCR where n is
the row number and R will be the number
in the range 0 to n let's try and
understand this better we saw how it
works for the third row n here is 3 and
our ranges from 0 to 3 what if we want
to find the terms in the 6th day of the
Pascal's triangle how do we do that we
know the relation between combinations
and each term right let's use that to
find out each term we have to find the
numbers in the sixth row so here and
will be equal to 6 and R will take
values from 0 to 6 by using the formula
of combinations we find the values of 6
C 0 6 C 1 6 C 2 and so on up to 6 C 6
try finding out each of these values
using the formula we saw earlier
we get these values as one six 15 2015 6
and one and yes these are the comps in
the sixth row of the Pascal's triangle
but why do we use combinations when we
can draw the Pascal's triangle and get
the values think about it now let's
assume we have to find the terms in the
eighth row will we draw the Pascal's
triangle up to the eighth row or will we
simply use combinations and get each
number yes we will use combinations
using combinations will make our work
much simpler
say we have to expand the binomial a
plus B raised to any positive integer we
know that to get the binomial
coefficients we can use the formula of
combinations but how do we get the other
terms consisting of a and B what do I
mean when I say other terms take these
two identities for instance now using
the combination formula we will get 1 2
1 and 1 3 3 1 but what about these parts
let's see look at the formula of a plus
B the whole cubed observe the first term
can you tell me the power of a here yes
it's 3 now tell me the power of a here
it's 2 and what's the power here the
power is 1 now what's the power of a in
the last term the last term does not
have a at all this means that the power
of a here is 0 so it's 3 2 1 0 now let's
look at B can you tell me the power of B
in each term
yes there 0 1 2 & 3 did you notice any
pattern in the powers of a and B yes we
observed that the power of a decreases
and the power of B increases in each
term for a the powers are 3 2 1 0 and
for B the powers are 0 1 2 3 let's try
and generalize a formula for this
consider a plus B raised to n where n is
any positive integer first let's write
the binomial coefficients given by the
formula of combinations so we have n C 0
and C 1 and C 2 and so on up to n CN
we've left gaps here because the terms
are not complete yet we can complete the
terms now we know that the power of a
decreases from left to right so let's
write a with each term having decreasing
powers we have a to the power n here how
do we write the power of a in the second
term now yes as the power decreases we
can write it as a to the power n minus 1
and then a to the power n minus 2 and so
on the last term will not have a as it's
a raise to 0 which is nothing but 1
we're not done yet what about B we write
be with each term having increasing
powers that is from 0 to n so can you
complete the formula now
here's how it will look the first term
will have B to the power 0 which is
nothing but 1 then we have B to the
power 1 which is B then B Square and so
on the last term will have B to the
power n there you go we have the general
formula which will help us expand the
binomial of any power very easily
[Music]